congressman warren davidson of ohio he's
been a big bitcoin proponent and he's
now taking it a step further there's
lots of talk of financial censorship
going on right now especially in canada
with the trucker convoy but congressman
davidson he's proposing a brand new bill
it's called the keep your coins act he's
recently tweeted and said our office
will be introducing legislation in the
u.s house of representatives shortly to
protect americans from this version of
overt theft specifically talking about
the freezing of bank accounts in canada
and he said please let your member of
congress and senators know he then
followed up this tweet with the
following comment where he said a number
of people will undoubtedly recognize
that bitcoin fixes this but that is only
true with self-custody account based
crypto has similar vulnerabilities we
also have a bill protecting self-custody
to keep your coins act now this is
important because today we've gotten
word that the canadian federal police
force has gone to regulated financial
firms and demanded that they not
transact with bitcoin addresses so if
the federal police in canada or other
law enforcement or government agencies
around the world are going to look for
central points of failure an ability to
actually cut off the use of bitcoin in
the financial system that means it
becomes really important to be able to
host your own wallet to actually have
sovereignty over your money and conduct
peer-to-peer transactions where you're
not reliant on a third party or a
middleman or a rent seeker in order to
actually finalize that transaction now
this keep your coins act would allow for
the protection of using virtual currency
or its equivalents for such users own
purposes such as to purchase real or
virtual goods and services for the
user's own use it'll also allow you to
conduct transactions through a
self-hosted wallet now this is super
important in a world where the
government wants to step in and actually
provide pressure to regulated financial
firms or to these regulated crypto firms
the ability to have your own sovereignty
over your money and to conduct
peer-to-peer transactions is essential
in this new world of surveillance and
authoritarian overreach now of course
we've got this tweet where if you
disagree with the government they will
take your money don't believe us look to
canada and if it can happen in a nice
country like canada it can happen
anywhere canada was previously seen as a
liberal democracy but it looks a lot
more like china than anything else right
now and so ultimately bitcoin is the
solution bitcoin was built for this
bitcoin quite literally fixes this but
we need to make sure that you're allowed
to use your bitcoin that you're allowed
to host it in a wallet yourself if you
have sovereignty over your money and
that you can conduct peer-to-peer
transactions congressman davidson and
his team that's what they're trying to
do with the keep your coins act i hope
it gets put through because ultimately
we need the government to stay out of
bitcoin hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time